Hello Freak bitches.
Hey Rory.
What's up buddy?
Hey Joe,
how are you doing this man?
I appreciate it.
And seriously,
I really appreciate you having me,
dude.
You have a fucking amazing story.
You have a Hollywood success story.
It's very,
it's,
it's the,
it's pretty get the stone
right up to your face,
so if you could hear it.
Yeah,
that feels good.
He'd be,
that's what I'm saying.
Can I get another one on my other sheet?
Fucking everywhere would
have put them all over you.
Sweet man.
I'm too.
You up.
Turn that off for a second.
I've got to do something.
No,
I,
it's,
it's very,
uh,
on Hollywood in the sense that I was in
New York and working at the daily show,
which is next to the horse
stables for central park.
Yeah,
I should say W it's a great showbiz story.
I guess so,
yeah.
It went from being like a PA to the
executive producer of the daily show and
that's fucking awesome.
Yeah,
well it was good.
It was not the,
uh,
I didn't know that that
was going to happen.
I got a job,
wanted to do comedy.
I wanted to do standup,
but I went to college,
so I felt weird coming out of college and
tell my parents I was just going to be
competing it,
you know,
like yeah,
remember all that money and stuff.
Like I'm just going to tell
jokes like I come from like,
uh,
my dad was like an old school Italian guy.
Like he doesn't understand
this kind of stuff.
He's like,
what?
What about a job?
You know what I mean?
Like get a job.
Like he would have been happier
if I said I was going to be a,
like a mailman or an electrician,
like that would have made
more sense than a job in TV.
So we're comedy in general,
so I got the job through were and like
that could at least justify the love of
comedy.
That's sort of makes sense.
Like,
look,
I'm working in the serious business.
Yeah.
Leave television shows
were very successful,
or at least I had to go somewhere.
Do you know what?
I think that was a big part of it.
It was like,
well,
what do you do when the
morning when the alarm was on?
Oh,
you don't have to get up in the morning
cause you just work at night and comedy
clubs like what?
Yeah,
the comics that we know that
don't do anything during the,
during the doll.
Yeah.
I mean they'd just fuck off
completely and totally get on stage,
which I'm always quite
jealous of actually.
You know,
I,
but I always had that
feeling when people go,
how do you do both?
I'm like,
well you know,
once during the day,
you know.
So that's one way to do both though.
As I got older,
I got more tired at night and it's harder
to go out and do clubs after the daily
show.
It is.
Right.
It's the hardest thing
in the world when you,
when you're on a set,
not the hardest thing in the world.
I shouldn't look compared
to anything else.
It's really easy.
It's as easy as fuck.
But I mean,
it's hard to work.
What I was going to say,
it's the hardest thing in the world to
work a full time job and then try to go
out and pursue something
because you're all your,
your juice has gone.
If you're,
I mean,
anything you're trying to do that's
like athletes that have full time jobs,
like fighters at a fulltime jobs.
Fuck,
that's hard.
And that's even harder because they have
hours of training they have to put in
every day.
But just when you're done
at the end of the day,
you're done.
You want to get a bite to eat,
watch TV.
You don't want to except for your
notes and fucking yet or the,
for me,
the other thing was too is still not
even at a place where like I walk in with
club and they're let go,
just get right up.
It's,
you know,
usually they're like,
why don't you clean up this
mess at 1:30 AM you know?
Um,
but I,
so for me it was a lot of,
it was just I loved doing the time,
but sometimes you've got to
hang out at the club and then,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
my bigger problem was because then I have
fun hanging out with other comics and
I have afterwards,
I have a couple of drinks and cause I
know like the harder problem was getting
up the next morning and be three hours.
Right.
So that's where I started to have that.
Uh,
you know,
well,
I'm doing,
the thing that was good about my day
job is it got me better at comedy,
so I didn't really lose the
like sort of experience.
I think I would've gotten on stage what
I didn't get by doing it every night for
a while was a,
you know,
like seasoned on stage.
It took me a little longer to get like
comfortable on stage to get back into the
groove.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But uh,
still,
uh,
it was a good experience.
Pa was fun.
That's amazing.
That's one of those stories that you're
going to ruin the expectations for every
fucking kid who,
everybody there obviously I have to say
at the daily show because it's been on
so long at John's such a cool guy and
like really gave people opportunities
there.
Um,
I was among the first people
to kind of make that journey,
but now have not been the only one.
That writer there was a PA that's amazing.
A bunch of the EPA,
the eps and peas and stuff where Peter's,
yeah,
like people can,
you know,
that's like a farm system almost
for good writing and producing.
It's pretty cool.
That's fantastic.
And it's become like for a lot
of people how they get the news.
Yeah.
That's a problem.
Isn't that weird?
Like that?
That's how people get
the new John Stewart.
Yeah.
People tell me that a lot.
They say,
well,
I guess where I get my news and I get it.
Like I remember being in
college would go to college,
kids get their news.
I felt like I didn't even watch
the news when I was in college.
Like,
I don't know,
you're in college,
you know,
so I guess it's better than nothing.
But,
uh,
I always tell people it's a good place
to start to get interested in a topic and
then go off and do your own
research or whatever you want.
Because when people get into political
debates off of like emails and like daily
show clips and they were like,
that's actually not true.
It's like,
you know,
they don't have like a real
understanding of each story necessarily,
you know?
Yeah.
It's weird thing,
isn't it?
When you're,
when you're,
when you're doing a television show that's
also an educational show and also has
like a very progressive
point of view are very,
what you would think of when you think
of John Stewart is like very intelligent,
very progressive,
mocking of both the left and the
right when they do ridiculous shit.
Yeah.
But it's gotta be funny for sure.
I mean that's a hard job.
Yeah.
Well it's really hard for him.
For me it was a lot easier
cause I got to watch him do it.
Right.
I mean,
that's the thing about John
that's amazing is he does all,
he's involved from 9:00 AM through the
end of the show obviously when he hosts
it.
But in other words,
she so intimately involved and he's so
smart and so sharp that like when he's in
the chair,
I never worried about a joke not working
because even when they didn't work,
he just would like call an audible and
his own head and then like remember a
joke from like the 90 and meeting that
he liked that didn't make the script and
throw that in or it's pretty amazing
to watch him to sitting in the studio
because he'll change a joke in prompter
as a prompter scrolling and then later
there's a call back to the joke.
He changed and he remembers the change
the callback or skip the call back.
And I'm like,
and I'm sitting there with the
script watching the prompter going,
oh no.
I'm like,
oh no,
here comes the callback.
Like we're screwed,
you know,
and then he's just jumps it or,
or,
or tags it with the jokey.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
It's really like watching
for that long too.
I mean,
he's fucking smooth.
He's so used to that Gig.
Like for Jimmy Fallon or me for Seth
Meyers who tried the same sort of an
impromptu ad Lib.
They might pull it off,
but Jon Stewart has been doing it forever.
Yeah.
Forever and ever.
Oh,
no doubt.
And he also,
uh,
yeah,
he just,
and he also just knows a lot.
What does a good comic too.
Yeah.
He's a great comic,
but he also just knows,
he understands comedy in a way that,
um,
I'm sure those,
I,
you know,
I know both Seth and Jimmy,
Super Funny Guy,
I just never worked with
them in that capacity.
So I know John understands it,
like music,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh No,
that won't work.
This will work.
You know,
and people go,
how do you know something's
going to work before you try it?
And it's like,
you just kind of know.
I don't know.
You just kind of know.
Well,
he also has a very specific voice.
He knows his voice and
his style of delivery.
Absolutely.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's an,
it's a fascinating show
because it's very political,
but yet very funny.
It's,
he doesn't sacrifice like going for funny.
Yeah.
Like to try to look like less
silly or try to look dignified.
He's not trying to monologue it.
Yeah.
No,
he's just making this stuff.
It's funny as you can and sometimes he
gets extremely animated and it's fucking
hilarious.
Yeah.
That,
I mean he's,
he's,
he's versatile in that sense.
Like he can really do and he tied comedy.
Yeah.
And uh,
but yeah,
as far as it,
I think it's,
cause it really is,
and people,
there's always bothers people
so much that was wanting to go,
oh,
what they think the daily
show us that can agenda.
I was like,
we're all sitting around
in a circle be like,
how do we screw the right?
It's like,
no,
it doesn't.
It's,
people don't believe that.
And they go,
Oh,
you're just hiding behind the
fact that it's a comedy show.
He'd go,
no.
Doing comedy is really hard.
There's nothing to hide.
Like we still have to take the stories.
We still tried to get everything right.
We have people who fact check.
There's a guy there named Adam
maciato coffee was like just a guru of
information and we'll come in
to the rewrite room between
rehearsal and the show
after we change a joke and I go,
you can't say this this way cause
it's statistically inaccurate to like
sometimes I'm like,
yeah man,
no one's going to care.
I can't say that,
but I'm saying it's not even,
it was a we're,
we're so we're,
we really fact check stuff
that goes out but the,
you know,
so it really,
a big part of the day is figuring
out how to tell the story,
the narrative and then adding
the jokes is why you have,
you know,
writers and guys like John,
then you can pile on the funny,
but funny is the most important thing.
There really is.
That's what's so fun.
That's why I stayed so long
because it's not like a,
uh,
I don't know.
It's,
there's no like movement happening.
There was just a comedy show.
Well that's why everybody
who gets so attached to it,
it's so crazy.
It's like they want it almost to be
more ideologically driven than it is.
You know?
It's like people would,
they would want it if he
said something ridiculous,
supportive and supportive of Obama,
they would like it.
Sure.
But if Obama fucks up,
he goes after him too all the time.
Yeah.
I mean that's the thing.
The show really became what it is or
what people think of it as now during the
Bush administration.
So I think people really associated with
being this like hardcore left wing a
show and it definitely slants laughed.
I mean it's hard sometimes for it not
to within in comedy because everything
that's when you're pointing out some
things are just straight up absurd.
Yeah.
It's hard sometimes not to seem left
cause you're throwing away like,
right.
You know?
So I think that's what people go.
Why don't people do a
right wing daily show?
It's like,
it's not really a left or a right thing.
It's just a lot of times comedy is
dismissive of people taking themselves too
seriously.
And Conservatives have a tendency
to take things very seriously.
You know what I'm saying?
That's exactly what they are.
They're conservative,
exacting,
more centered.
Comic by nature is the guy sitting in
the back of the classroom being like,
look at his dick.
You know,
it's like you don't really care.
You know what the person's saying,
you're just finding places to get a laugh.
And I think so for us,
like when the left does sort of things,
which is also quite frequent,
like occupy Wall Street.
Yeah.
Was a perfect example of my
favorite times at the daily show.
Well were like ripping the left
and new asshole and the audience,
cause I'm in the studio,
we're used to be.
And the audience is like,
what are you guys doing man John,
this is our movement man.
And he's,
and they'll let you
know I don't like they,
if they zip up their zip,
he's over there.
John Stewart for president t shirts.
Gosh,
Shit.
And for me it was like we crush those
dudes and then I'd go to the desk between
commercials and we'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
it's a standups mentality.
Like do you feel the crowd?
Like,
I just came back from Madison,
Wisconsin this weekend.
And it's an amazing city.
Like the,
the club is awesome.
The shows were so fun,
but they were,
it was grown.
They,
there were groans from the crowd
on certain things I would say,
cause it was this college town,
right?
And colleges now are really at like,
I know that's like a,
a taboo right wing thing to say,
but there's a left wing
political correctness in
college now that is an extreme
extreme.
And I remember like 10 years ago doing a
college gig is very different than now.
You make a joke about being like,
whoa.
And that was happening
in Madison and there's,
you know,
as a comic,
right?
Like you feel that from
the crowd and you go,
wait,
what just happened?
Yeah.
And then you,
you know,
you want to like poke it a little bit.
So on the daily show,
John's a comic,
but we hit it,
well,
we hit a note on something.
We were going after Hillary
in Oh eight same thing.
Go.
What do you guys do it?
I don't know.
Doing what we do and making fun
of people who were in charge,
like,
you know,
it's sorry.
You don't,
it's selective outrage.
Yeah.